Brendan is going to show us what a head
kick is and how he sets one up I'm just
not going to throw a hectic kid you got
to set it up if you're gonna land
because I'm going to see it a lot of
times right yeah it's easy to see a one
you're gonna see that all day and salute
it so I'm gonna set it up by throwing a
left hook to get his head over here so
it's gonna look like this boom bam so
when I saw this left hook he's gonna go
to where I wanted to go you don't hit me
that hard please yeah it does I feel
like my head's being around go on sorry
man so I'm gonna throw this left hook
and step out to line this right kick up
here here
boom so again left hook here to get your
stuff out here right and just tight for
this boom it's not a good time how you
gonna defend this B what are you gonna
do well very simply we're at your house
you take the last piece of cheese you
know I love cheese right I'm like a
giant mouse I'm gonna step out of the
way I'm gonna come in I'm gonna bait I'm
gonna step again and I'm gonna kick him
with a front foot and the douche